and if the partial government shutdown
doesn't end today some 800,000 federal
workers will miss another paycheck on
Friday now that would be the second time
federal workers have gone without pay
since the shutdown began 32 days ago
Senate Republicans proposed a bill to
reopen the government last night but
Democrats are not expected to support it
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning I feel like it's deja
vu all over again it feels that way nor
a good morning everyone for federal
workers to be paid on Friday the
government has got to start processing
those paychecks tonight to do that you
need a legislative compromise and a
presidential signature we're not going
to get that the most that will happen
today is the president's proposal
outlined this weekend will be introduced
in the Senate not clear when that votes
going to occur meanwhile federal workers
trying to make ends meet are finding
that more difficult and more frightening
by the day
great day it's beautiful day the
president briefly paid his respects to
dr. Martin Luther King jr. Monday
morning but ignored questions about the
seemingly endless government shutdown
Senate Republicans plan to vote on the
president's immigration proposal this
week which includes three years
protection from deportation for some
refugees and so-called dreamers it also
includes 5.7 billion dollars for a
border wall a non-starter with Democrats
federal workers meanwhile twist in the
partisan wind when that one income is
cut off it's kind of scary
many like Chicago area Food and Drug
Administration investigator Larry
stringer and his wife Ellen faced
unexpected hardships all of the money
that we have set aside is to prepare for
our son Joey's future needs he's 18 and
has severe autism the family is paying
for Joey's nutritional supplements and
medical needs by dipping into their
savings which will run out soon we will
eventually not be able to care for him
anymore in our home and he will have to
go into a residential facility the other
alternative is he would become a ward of
the state and you know that just breaks
our heart Larry has overseen food safety
inspections for both Democratic and
Republican presidential inaugurations
including president Trump's but he is
taking no
sighs I want to go back to work I love
my job
like other cash-strapped federal workers
and contractors Larry and Ellen just
want to protect their children we hug
him tight every day and just try to
reassure the kids that everything's
going to be okay House Democrats will
offer legislation to provide some
protections for federal workers but
beyond it appears both sides are
striking legislative poses not reaching
a hard-fought compromise and once again
real Americans paying the price for
gridlock in Washington major thank you